foreign
primarily an economic issue or is it
um a tool of morality you know we've
heard about how we shouldn't trade with
countries that are moving away from our
values and countries that are you know
coming closer to our values make sense
um but then also we hear all the
arguments about you know the closest the
closest neighbor it's most economically
viable which which is the more important
aspect the moral or the economic Andrew
if you want to I don't really think you
can divorce them um uh the Adam Smith
who wrote The Wealth of Nations also
wrote The Theory of Marvel sentiments he
never ever sought to divorce moral
precepts from um uh rules of the markets
the two go hand in hand and these are
these are judgment calls you make at the
time you know the the the China that was
opening up to the West seriously 20
years ago was a very different place
from the one that's now engaging in a
genocide against the uyghurs the Russia
of Gorbachev Gladstone Austin
perestroika and what we thought might
become democracy is a fundamentally
different place from the one that is
ripping up all all laws of international
law invading its neighbors annexing
their territory holding fake referendums
and engaging in something akin to
genocide in the areas of the Ukraine
that it's operating in so you can't
separate the two and you need to um keep
the two in in Tandem and in conditions
where you've got a greater degree of um
of moral agreement you're going to have
more trade where you have a lesser
degree of moral agreement you're going
to have less trade and there are
conditions you know AKA North Korea
where you'll have no trade at all
um can we justify initiating a trade War
if it's at the Active uh detriment to
citizens of your own country
I'm hoping the discussion John has we'll
have a lot of views on this one John
um
the question really is should we use
trade
as an instrument of foreign policy
and I think the answer in principle has
to be there is no reason why we
shouldn't the answer in practice is I
think that attempts to do so have mostly
been pretty unsuccessful uh Gina quoted
the example of South Africa
which is a possible example of where
using it as an instrument of foreign
policy was successful I'm not sure I
agree that sanctions and Western
sanctions and aspects of trade had very
much to do with the ultimate collapse of
Apartheid
but that's about the best case one can
produce the truth is that the sanctions
which we the economic sanctions which
we've imposed against Russia have if
anything been counterproductive that is
we have raised the price of energy to
levels which have been effectively
financing Putin's War this is not as it
were strangle the Russian economy and
forced it to to make peace it does if
anything done the opposite the historic
examples of economic sanctions being
very successfully pursued are pretty
Limited
theoretically first is trade economical
model basically trade for me is economic
what is the purpose of trade it is to
make yourself and the trading partner
better off you know that's the whole
theory behind trade and
um in best conditions it works then at
some point you can make the moral
judgment say do you want to make this
country or this person better off and
then there will be certain countries or
certain groups that you don't want to
make better off because they'll
strengthen them and they might even get
back at you with that strength which is
part of I think what someone sees with
Russia right now and you also
particularly you don't want to dependent
be dependent on a trading partner that
might turn on you
um which is again what we see with
Germany having become dependent on on
Russian gas but
as a woman in this world I was you know
not see much trade if we started to say
we don't want to trade with those who
don't treat us with the human rights we
get cut out the whole Arab world cut up
Japan cut out China I mean so we could
trade with ourselves a bit I think one
has to be practical and to say yeah what
is trade about trade is about people
have something that you would like to
have and you have something they would
like to have and in that little box uh
that makes everyone better off and then
we can again as I said use that the
power of stopping trade in certain
situations but I actually agree with
John that
trade and Bargas have in many cases not
produce the results that one wanted to
see and often it somehow
gives an impetus to people who have I
mean embargo against them to stand
together there's a strength in that even
against I think was it Austria in
I can't remember which year it was not
that many years ago where they had
implemented some quite strong uh
policies against immigrants before the
rest of Europe followed at that time
still Europe went down on and posed an
embargo on Austria it didn't work at all
so I'm just I'm wondering
um John is skeptical about the efficacy
of sanctions um Andrew would you be able
to make the case for them well trade by
definition is a two-way thing they they
don't want to trade as much with us at
the moment let's be clear what's
happening at the moment we did not bomb
our own pipeline which was which was
producing
um uh energy from Russia that was done
by them so this point about whether
you're moving towards or against is
hugely important in terms of trade I
also um I don't accept that sanctions
don't have an effect I think you need
constantly as in all forms of um of
diplomacy and economic diplomacy is the
same as all others you need to learn and
improve uh sanctions against individuals
can be extremely effective and indeed
the extent to which the individuals in
question who have been subject to
massive personal sanctions in the case
of the Russian Elite have sought to
evade those sanctions to get around them
and to have them laid aside so they can
enjoy their huge houses here in London
and their Penthouse Apartments in New
York is quite telling and they would be
doing that if they didn't think that
they were effective so you constantly
need to improve your sanctions but the
idea that in this interchange between
states where you're seeking to create
zones of stability and if you believe in
moral precepts as we do of democracy the
rule of law and human rights you
shouldn't be seeking to advance them I
think it's totally unrealistic that you
wouldn't seek to do that but it requires
judgment and what may apply in one
circumstance won't apply in any other
would find others and it is there is a
big and fundamental difference in in my
experience of government and dealing
with with um overseas government as to
whether fun if they are in the category
we've talked about which is basically
authoritarian whether they are
fundamentally moving towards you or
fundamentally moving against if they're
moving towards you the whole climate in
which you conduct diplomacy and trade is
fundamentally more
open and reciprocal than if they're
moving against you and there has rarely
been a case of a country moving against
us so dramatically as uh Russia since it
invaded its European neighbor on
February the 24th
okay thank you Andrew I think I want to
move um on to a few more examples so um
John said in his opening statement this
idea of countries that share our values
or don't share our values as kind of a
weird binary and so you know we've had a
lot of talk about Russia I'm interested
in talking more about China perhaps
Saudi Arabia and where do we decide
where that threshold of sharing our
values is you talk about it's a movement
thing rather than a fixed thing but you
know there are obviously many countries
with which we share some values but not
all values India Springs to mind perhaps
um and I want to know John uh how you
see that topography
I mean we people here share very few
values with Saudi Arabia either at the
government level or at the individual
level
but if you ask what is an effect what is
the main liberalizing effect in Saudi
Arabia it is openness to the west and
the fact that they they need us
to to buy their oil in order to support
their regime if we are is are we doing
good for Saudi Arabia about trading with
Saudi Arabia it's complicated because
we're supporting Saudi Arabian
corruption
but we're also supporting the
importation of our kind of values at the
individual level into Saudi Arabia in
ways that is having a dramatic effect
and will have a more dramatic effect
over time when people in that country
realize they don't have to live in the
way in which they lived historically
especially women it changes everything
and it is changing everything
so in general I think um
I'm not in principle against using trade
as a weapon for spreading our our moral
values I think it's much more relevant
at the individual and individual
business level than it is at the
national level for reasons I've
described I'm skeptical about what the
both about what the ideas of idea of
national values is in this sense and the
the positive effects I'm describing are
the result of trade at the level of the
individual and the and the particular
business not the results of trade
at the national level
Betrayed at the individual and business
level is actually one of the main means
by which we share our values or we
spread our values because that's the way
in which we have relations with a lot of
people uh who are not uh who are not
part of our family who are not part of
our kin it is an economic relation and
by uh influencing the ways in which we
trade we can export the kind of values
of Tolerance human rights and the like
which which we applaud yeah
you know when we talk about Saudi Arabia
is the fact that how come that when a
country has such different values than
us and is popped up uh by the money we
pour into
the regime then can hold down the
population with with those funds that we
have not diverted away from oil much
earlier there's I mean
such interest in the financial earnings
of the oil industry that we couldn't
take them all position on Saudi Arabia
but we should have and I do agree that
when we trade and it opens societies and
we can influence you know indirectly
through that unfortunately I think in
the case of Saudi Arabia
uh
not enough interaction actually flows
into the society with the trade it's
very much you know the regime that takes
the advantage but imagine the strength
we do that is not through direct you
know trade flow stopping but if we
diverted our dependence on that energy
source called oil but you know even with
Russia the whole thing is dependence on
the gas we can
change that by changing our consumption
of energy you know or the composition of
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas